I mean what do we what are we doing here
Liz this is insane
cake pie equally delicious right
but are they because people have a lot
of strong opinions about them so today
we're inviting people from both camps to
state their cases maybe we'll finally
settle the age-old debate which is
better pie or cake I was born a man of
pie I far prefer cakes to pies I'm a pie
advocate because I'm a grown-ass man
I am a cake enthusiast team pie team
cake
I just hate cake I'm ready to [ __ ]
fight about some cherry pie
people eat pies every day because a pie
is acceptable a cake is not acceptable
every day you pie every day you're gonna
have any pie for breakfast you start
having cake for breakfast you look like
a goddamn fool a pie it's a step above a
pop-tart
it really is I'll [ __ ] with a pop-tart
fresh out of the toaster then I'll ever
touch some pie you go to Starbucks need
to see a cake represented as breakfast
food more than you'd see a pie there's
not like a bunch of cakes at Starbucks
there's cake pops which are not
breakfast they're [ __ ] snacks for
crazy people that is not the color of
food I'm sorry but this pecan pie looks
like [ __ ] you think this looks like [ __ ]
it does look like [ __ ] oh I'm sorry
compared to the beauty of this you have
that artificial frosting which is bad
for everything and everybody I guarantee
that's yellow 5 I promise that shrinks
penises you also get chicken pot pie
there's like 30 textures in that [ __ ] if
anyone ever tries to serve me a meat
cake I'm gonna [ __ ] throw it in their
face once you can have chicken and a pie
you've won the game there's no chicken
cake listen that's true there are savory
pies out there and I don't know what
we're gonna do about that crust look we
all love crust there's no gettin around
that it can be savory or sweet and it's
not one-dimensional like a cake a cake
isn't one-dimensional it's literally
layered pies versatile yeah you know
what else is versatile minivan you know
Honda Honda our desire I Drive a minivan
and I love it pi is the Model T of
deserts it was like it was cool in the
30s like you put on the windowsill like
that was awesome what do you drive
what's the cake equivalent of
automobiles a Hyundai Sonata oh yeah
it's a real cake car why would you have
a Toyota when you could have a Ferrari
okay that's it all I'm sorry of a PI's a
Ferrari a pie a pie the Pony Express
yeah babe this right here this little
yellow number this is a Lambo pie can be
made with nuts with fruits with meats
pie is everything we've wanted it's even
a gross term for a sexual part it is
yeah Gina cake is more of an event you
know we're having a piece of cake we're
really celebrating pie is like oh cool
your grandma's over let's have some you
know pie you don't celebrate special
occasions with pie and when it was my
birthday in the office they bought me a
pie and it was it was pretty [ __ ]
good yeah what do you do on your wedding
day
are you married Colin no the same just
just put that in your head for a second
birthday pie no wedding pie yeah like
this is just crap crap crap crap crap
crap the only reason that cakes are done
that way that the popular item is cuz
they're cheaper the most popular flavor
of cake is vanilla vanilla is a word for
boring look how simple your food looks
and you're such an American does
everything have to look like a goddamn
roller coaster yes
who likes sweet bread like you're eating
bread that's sweet who likes sweet bread
her words not mine
I love sweetbreads you love sweetbreads
we love cake but if you were to go to
like a fancy cake maker oh my god I
wouldn't even want to eat it because
it's so beautiful that actually is it
are good for pie
let me cut you a good slice of cake all
right all of these revolts me there's so
much frosting on it do I have to eat it
honestly like I know what it tastes like
guess what it's [ __ ] vanilla what a
surprise doesn't even good cake oh oh
it's so sugary I wouldn't want a piece
of hard fruit in my thing that I really
got through sugar bread and sugar what
variety I've been blessed to enjoy it's
like eating candy you know what you can
go home and like eat your runts and
sleep in your racecar bed and be the
child that you want to be that's fine
but I'm just saying like real adults eat
pie that's agree on something though how
do you feel about strudel that [ __ ]
makes me so uncomfortable Oh Google
nothing patrick said has changed my mind
i'm still firm believer in pi pi is sure
it's good how are you it's subtle we've
done here I got work to do I'm an adult
what do you think red velvet is Patrick
it's not chocolate it's yours healthy
chocolate no it's you wear hats on your
feet and you put shoes on your head
that's your pie logic